the live and Alive tour is off and
running Tulsa Oklahoma September 15th
and 16th Phoenix Arizona September 29th
and 30th get your tickets to all shows
at ryansickler.com
[Music]
the Honeydew with Brian sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pass
Studios I'm Ryan sicklerionsickler.com
Ryan sickler on all your social media I
want to say thank you as always thank
you for supporting this community thank
you for supporting this channel we're
over 200 000 subscribers now thank you
for supporting the special just cross
700 000 even after being pulled out of
the algorithm so thank you very much I
can tell you all are supporting it if
you haven't watch it share it comment
that's how these things keep going all
right that's how we make more for you
and if you gotta have more speaking of
more then you gotta check out our
patreon it's called the Honeydew with
you all and I highlight the low lights
with you all and I say it every week
here I say it every week there
you never know what we're going to hear
next week There's no way it's going to
be able to and then we hear the wildest
stories you've ever heard in your life
it's five bucks a month you sign up for
a year you get over a month free you get
the Honeydew a day early you get it ad
free you get it at no additional cost
but listen if you or someone you know
has a story that has to be heard please
submit it to honeydew podcast gmail.com
you do not need to be a patreon member
we just want to know your Story come on
hopefully we'll get to share it all
right if you're looking for a new
podcast to listen to go listen to my old
podcast the crab Feast it's going to do
a million downloads this year do you
understand how that podcast has been
dead for almost five years and that
library is going to do over a million
downloads this year it is still a wildly
active group go check it out it's got
all the people you know and love from
podcasting on there everybody's there
with different stories all right it's
Audio Only from back in the day go check
it out all right come see me on the road
if you're in town when I'm in your town
Springfield Missouri September 1st and
2nd I'll be in Tulsa September 15th 16th
Phoenix Arizona I'm back on September
29th and the 30th Salt Lake City October
27th 28th Batavia Illinois November 10th
and 11th and San Francisco December 8th
and 9th that's it that's the biz you
guys know we do over here we highlight
the low lights I always say these are
the stories behind the storytellers and
I am very excited to have the guests on
here this week first time here on the
Honeydew ladies and Gentlemen please
welcome Moses storm welcome yeah you do
heads thank you the doobies
dude it's been a year literally yeah
we're shooting this in July now I I
talked to you at Montreal last year I
was like dude I would love to have you
yeah yeah as a power move um well I'm
very excited to get into your story but
before we do please plug promote
everything and anything you would like
oh yeah so the best introduction to me
is the special I have on HBO or HBO Max
or Max whatever it's called Uh called
trash white and it's something I put
everything into it came out in 2022 it's
called trash white and it's uh I built
the set I edited the entire special I
directed it uh color correct put
everything into it made my own costume
and then obviously yeah the whole set
that's that's the main thing so that's a
great introductory if you like that then
come out and see me uh at the Elation
theater on July 30th I'm doing my part
two to that show which normally comedy
specials don't have a cliffhanger but
this is the part two to that one it's
called perfect cult where I start the
perfect cult with the audience there
that night everyone gets a robe it's
interactive immersive theater meets
stand-up comedy I have no idea if it's
going to work or not that's why I need
people to come out and let me fail in
front of them and then I'm going to
Edinburgh Scotland for The Fringe
Festival for the entire month of August
at the Pleasants theater
um and I'm running perfect call every
single night sometimes two times a night
there at the special and then I come
back to Los Angeles and then September
30th back at the Elation doing another
run of perfect cult and then uh then off
to New York to do it there
but it's an interactive show that I it's
like irresponsible the amount that I
need the audience to participate and to
come out I if it's less than six people
I physically cannot do the show
is that right it has to be a minimum six
half a dozen y'all come on Scotland show
up
um well I want to talk I feel like a lot
of people throw the word cult around
these days and I know that you're not
throwing it around so I'm gonna let you
drive this bus bro please tell us your
story uh yeah take it from wherever
you'd like okay because yeah usually you
are right people throw it around and
cult usually means like oh you were in
an acting class where the guy got
perfect right yeah it's a scam acting
class
tantric acting
um but I was raised and essentially an
unsuccessful doomsday cult that my
parents helped start
oh whoa they're Founders they are
founders but they're not the top which
is a little hard to swallow I wish they
were the top there's only three families
in the call okay early 90s is when they
start explain where where are you from
where are we starting it starts in
Kalamazoo Michigan okay Kalamazoo and it
starts with my great uncle do you know
about the Kalamazoo kangaroos by any
chance no they were like a really
talented jump rope team that sounds like
a like a like a radio morning radio the
kangaroo
the gay Zoo kangaroo there were some
kids that moved to our neighborhood when
we were little and they had uh Kalamazoo
Kangaroos and the girl was like she kick
ass on the jump rope like what are you
she's like where what year is this so
jump rope is like I'm in the 80s so 80s
that's you're the [__] yeah in the 80s
if you can jump rope because there's not
really video if you're on a team for it
you're going to be here all right I'm
sorry okay so uh yeah so in the late 80s
is when they first joined my mom's the
one that really wears the pants or the
relationship so she's the one that got
my dad on board with this call it
started by my great uncle
and he has like big come to Jesus moment
this is why he's the enlightened one
he's the chosen one that's why I have
some pamphlets for you tonight great to
share with you
um so what happens is he's like a star
running back at Michigan State your
uncle yeah at the time and he's just
like short fat stocky guy so it's kind
of impressive that he doesn't look like
an athlete he's this guy this short guy
can move and he's always scoring for the
team he's partying he's got this whole
identity as a psychology football star
maybe the NFL and then he gets hit
incredibly hard on the football field
and he wakes up he's already in a
Stretcher everyone in the stands he got
knocked out knocked out
completely so he wakes up and everyone's
on their feet in the stands with what
you do and he's being carted off the
field and he's still a little dizzy and
then he sees the heavens roll back like
a scroll and then God himself comes down
onto the football field and says Neymar
Dak did you are the chosen one yeah
every other religion is wrong
Christianity Judaism Islam
um Catholicism all wrong government's
wrong public school system is all wrong
this is what he's hearing as he's being
rolled off the phone yes after a major
head injury major head injury we now
know what he's experiencing is not a
miracle it's CTE it is a massive
concussion yeah which in hindsight like
it is impressive that he was able to
start even a failed call with a
concussion like as far as like people
with CTE impressive the embarrassing
part is that my parents heard that same
story and they were like yeah this guy
with the brain injury is on to something
Have you ever spoke do you talk to your
uncle have you ever talked to him
everything fell apart in 2000. did he
say God looked like something because he
was like also this way cult is used
people say God and in their mind it's
Jesus yeah and I know we could say Jesus
is his son all that I mean did God look
like anything in his story because he's
a pretty compelling speaker it's not old
man with a Long White Beard and long
hair or really looks like man it's it's
almost a pure light that comes down okay
and speaks with a very commanding voice
and says it's your mission English it
speaks English he speaks English
yeah but no Jesus is white and he's from
the Middle East in the Southern drawl
yeah Southern drawl man blonde hair and
then baby blue eyes
so so God tells him that he's the only
chosen one he's essentially the next
prophet and that God's gonna end the
world and it's going to be horrible it's
going to be the Book of Revelation which
is like the four horsemen come down
there's flaming there's there's uh
locusts there's bugs just this horrible
Armageddon and that was like really what
our religion or our cult was focused on
is this impending thing that will happen
I believe this was absolutely going to
happen in the most horrific ways so are
you I'm gonna keep asking questions I
apologize in this cult does the cult
have a religion that's already
established or are you also creating
your own religion as well they are using
the King James Bible and if you had to
map it something close to what it is
it's a mixture of Judaism and
Catholicism okay and just like the unfun
parts of that great where it gets really
culty is like what most Cults do is they
isolate people so we are not allowed to
interact with anyone that is not in this
exact religion and that's what makes it
a cult that's what makes it a cult is
Extreme control and then it's all
dedicated to one leader at the top
and what he says goes he's the
enlightened one so it doesn't matter if
you have an objection doesn't matter if
he's wrong so your uncle's you're David
koresh he's our David koresh my parents
will like let him spank us let him hit
us do anything that he wants because he
is why okay so he's Wheeling off he's
got to say in our life so he said that
you guys should we're renting this like
one bedroom house I have uh four
siblings and my mom dad so five kids and
and we we stopped renting that house and
we buy an old Greyhound bus
for seven thousand dollars we had two
thousand dollars but then uh my mom I
asked my mom like how we were able to
afford that she says oh well we just
traded a bunch of junk from our backyard
it was the 90s everyone was trading then
like that was an answer but she traded a
bunch of trash in her backyard for this
bus my dad doesn't know anything about
construction rips the seats out and
tries to build it into an RV and the
whole purpose of this this is like 1992
is that we're gonna travel around state
to state in the U.S and spread the word
this wasn't just a live-in this was the
travel this was to travel and get the
word out all right before we get to that
how when your uncle comes to and
everything he's still convinced this
happened he's going with it how is he
able to convince your mom and dad
so uh so so yeah so he gets carved up
the field his ACL is torn in addition to
the concussion so he knows it's over and
before he had this whole identity as his
football star this jock he's hooking up
with chicks he's got the life and if I
had to speculate it would be like oh
finding a religion being the the Messiah
is a new way to be that star running
back
it's a new way that makes you special
it's a new way to get attention you have
something that other people don't so I
think that was very enticing he already
grew up very Catholic
so and he's performing it in Sundays or
Saturdays College in an arena in an
arena in front of people so how do you
create that that feeling of the star
linebacker again if you know your NFL
career is over the last two years of
college PJs do you know that that's why
Shaq DJ that's why he DJs why was he a
cop uh I think his that's a good
question yeah I don't know if his
stepfather or who he considers his dad
was and he was always into law
enforcement but he I saw this I love
Shaq and I watched this doc on him and
he said the reason he DJs is because he
misses that like where else in life am I
gonna go now and get 20 000 people
cheering for me and he's like EDM
festivals bro right those and DJs and
they all go nuts and you don't need it
that that can get broken right uh side
note if anyone can that listens to your
podcast can find us or maybe it would
make me so happy but Shaq had a
short-lived prank show where he would
dress up in just like a wig but uh joke
I'll be Uber and people immediately
recognize yeah
there is a giant man in the front seat
it's like
yeah and he he did no effort to change
his voice at all but work a Cold Stone
Creamery and the people the whole show
was just people going oh my God it's
Jack oh my God you totally got us we
didn't know that Shaq was gonna be yeah
here there's no that he never fools
anyone the whole show is people just
getting excited to meet Shaq I I don't
know where this was at or we're
short-lived but wherever that is I would
make me so happy to see that again
uh so then he he comes to and my mom was
very popular in her High School
terrible student homecoming queen
um very very attractive so she didn't
really pay attention a lot and then now
high school's over so I think that if he
was starting this this cult this
religion here's something that's special
especially in Kalamazoo Michigan where
people live pretty normal Suburban lives
this is pretty enticing of like oh you
could be special you don't have to just
clip coupons and pop out a bunch of kids
so
she was already very religious my
parents weren't in love they were just
pregnant with my oldest sister
um according to my mom my dad was gay
when they met
and he was so guilty that he was gay and
the religion didn't accept that the
religion that he grew up he was like
pretty Christian
um so then he's like oh you will fix it
even though it's fornicating if I have
sex with a woman then that will turn me
straight
the first time he did that with my mom
they get pregnant
hold on the thought processes I am gay
but if I have sex with a woman then that
will make me straight
even though we all know that's not gonna
yeah my dad says he's like bi and then
he experimented and a lot of the stuff
about him being gay is like from my mom
like being very vindictive and trying to
spread stories about him and say like
your father's gay he's awful but I don't
so I don't know fully what it is but but
what she would tell us is that yeah he
was gay so that they they had to
fornicate so he could stop being gay and
the first time
he gets and he's got five kids with her
which means every time he's blowing a
load he's blowing a baby successful
loads he's not like wanting sex he's
like yum grass so then every time that
he comes he a baby comes out
fully formed baby he's not even in my
mom
so no way that's what happens and then
she's he's kind of a pushover he's like
are they married they were married the
second they found out they were pregnant
they're like we have to rush they had a
very rushed wedding it was never like
should we keep the baby should we do
this it was just how do we find a
wedding dress that's gonna cover the
baby bump without being obvious that
we're covering so they have a very quick
quick wedding and for some reason my mom
likes to tell the story of like he was
late for our wedding because he was
taking a bath with a man
she's like how do you know that yeah
right and he's saying he's like they
picture her at the altar where are you
and he's soaking
um so then she's able to essentially
convince him to sign up with this
because she really wears the pants in
the family
and at this point they already have uh
three kids and then I'm born so then
they're all in but they're just staying
in in Michigan and then now we're in
Ohio basically the same thing even
though they have dumb rivalries and as
they're doing that are they slowly also
building this cult they're still
building the bus in the driveway of this
rental house and it's renting it so the
owners hate that we're doing this it's
very loud my dad's horrible at
construction nothing works he made bunk
beds three high but he forgot to measure
for the height of a mattress on top of
the platform so your dad can make babies
but not bunk beds
good at everything I grew up in a closet
I'm gonna have to like scoot the blanket
no [__] that that's how you bring that
yeah oh God and then the bus is moving
and then the style of GMC Greyhound bus
the engine is the hot diesel engine is
in the back of the bus which is where
our bunk beds were three on each side so
that would just heat up the air would
get all wavy and it just always sucking
exhaust and everything sucking exhaust
it's the best melatonin just knock you
out
and and then so then we would do a
little bit of street preaching in Ohio
Wood Street preaching street preaching
as you go out to any crowded area if you
would if we're here we go to the Grove
if you're in New York you go to Times
Square also you're going to populating
things
um outside of Coachella or Lollapalooza
at the time we would uh yeah anywhere
that's even a farmer's market and you go
out with these large neon signs with
essentially click bait on the signs
because you only have so much time to
get people's attention so use the same
tactics that people that write clickbait
articles do
so it was all like you're headed for
hell Christian Christians will burn just
the most eye-catching hateful stuff uh
you are headed for how your children are
gonna burn in hell that's the most
insane things so that you get people's
interests that's the hardest thing is to
get people to stop and not like you know
just pass you out two questions I'm
assuming Maybe I'm Wrong the majority of
the interaction you're getting is it not
confrontational or people coming over
like how could you put this about my
children on the side or is it genuine
curiosity like what percentage it is a
lot of hate I think I think there
definitely was indifference but what
stands out in my mind and what your
memory records is the immense amount of
negative reaction people not just why
are you saying that about my kids why
are you saying that about my faith
you're saying who the hell are you to
say I'm gonna burn but because we were
out there as early as two years old
people are yelling at my parents how
could you put your children through yes
because they would make us go up and
it's called witnessing for God where as
soon as you can talk and I could talk
pretty early is you'd go up to a
stranger as a two-year-old or I think I
went up at four maybe and I would go up
to an adult and just the tracks at hand
they don't know what I'm I'm there for
and their child never comes up to you so
if a kid comes up to you that's like oh
my God hi hi little buddy in a bit your
head for hell
[__]
[Music]
just the most adorable Hellfire preacher
if you like what did you just say to me
this cute little evil bastard right here
you're full of sand your kids are going
to Born holy [__] just adorable I'm out
of hate and then they're coming over me
like what do you remember abusing your
kids or whatever yeah then I passed them
a track and then they would see that the
large neon signs it's like maybe 14 feet
in the air six foot high signs with with
like black block letters over just neon
um was all those like clickbait articles
then my dad would have a big fanny pack
with all the tracks and it
um another problem is the cult didn't
have internet access is that your paper
trucks is like the pamphlet that you
pass out with our beliefs on it okay and
who's wrong
didn't have a name didn't have a name
that's a little tough you were
interested right hey come on Ryan
stickler's podcast what's it called it's
no name also it's called No Name cool no
it's it has somebody named it yet yeah
yeah you gotta check out the show it's
got no name what is the the other
question I want to ask is what is the
conversion rate do you actually get
people if you're out of a Lollapalooza
yeah you'll get a couple people that
will come over talk to and then be like
hey I think this is for me so I guess
the impressive thing is like when it
started in the late 80s early 90s
there's only three families in the call
by the time it disbanded in 99 2000
there were three families in the car
conversion rate sometimes we would hang
out with us and then the way they
figured out that we didn't have weed
that no one wasn't made in the womb of
an already believer that is hilarious
zero members nobody wanted to be a part
of it and we never never got one do you
ever watch like any of the Netflix cult
documentaries so you know like the
episode two where they play the song
like spirit in the sky and everything is
going well and everyone's doing yoga in
the Sun and they're building a compound
and and celebrities are getting involved
and then they take the dark turn we
never had that build up Mom you've ever
had episodes we've never had episode two
there was no yoga there was no period
where this was going well
there was no positive press there was no
like oh my God we're expanding it was
just a miserable slog of a failure with
poverty people like we've got on the
spring break Street preach and peeing in
bottles and then throwing it at our
signs people screaming at us or mooning
us
um people obviously yelling at my
parents people trying to rip down the
signs or spitting on physical or
spinning yeah see I watched um
it was right here I was with my daughter
we were in Santa Monica and someone was
preaching
um it was against gays the man had a
sign is you know gays burn in hell or
whatever and
I get why this gay gentleman was so
[__] angry but he went over and he
spit right in that man's face and that
man smiled and just basically was like
see you know what I mean and it made and
I was like uh like I'm so glad you
brought that up yeah because that's the
whole point is the Bible and this
religion taught that people will scoff
at you and people will get angry so if
anything it just reinformed their sense
of righteousness that oh we are doing
the right thing because the people hated
Jesus They Crucified him so we're
basically doing the right thing so there
was no cause for them to reflect and be
like wait what are we doing if anything
it just reaffirmed these these hateful
intolerant beliefs he's like oh yeah
people are bad there's an example
everyone this is what I'm saying and
there it is it lived out and I get why
that guy was like [__] you you piece of
[__] but yeah it did end up making him
look like the the aggressor and the you
know right guys so right especially in
America which is the only way you can
get away with this with the freedom of
religion so so then people are yelling
at us to say hey why aren't your kids in
school that's my next question you're
still on the road where does the
education come from so I would say we're
homeschool but that would be too
generous there was no school nothing if
you ask the government and when we go
get welfare from the government
um we're homeschooled but there is no
school there was like a little bit of an
attempt to do homeschool with my two
oldest siblings
um but then by the time we got to my
older brother myself and then my younger
sister really no school was ever
enforced if anything it's like study the
Bible I taught myself how to read which
is like you can sing how to read and off
of what what were you looking at so I
would try to sound out words pretend I
would like memorize things really fast
in the Bible if I heard something
so then I would pretend to read because
I'd know that I would get spanked if I
didn't like say a Bible verse correctly
you would yeah so I'd memorize it but I
didn't find out until I was 22 that I
was dyslexic and dysgraphic because
there was no testing for what's this
graphic this graphic is the order of
things if you told me a phone number my
my brain couldn't make a picture of the
order of the things the best way I could
describe it'd be like I thought that was
all dyslexia it's not dyslexia is more
complicated you're reading with every
part of your brain which is why people
that are dyslexic get exhausted when
they read most people just read with
their frontal cortex and it's just it
relegates to this one part that's why
you can focus dyslexic you're reading
with every part they have CAT scans
where every part of the brain lights up
so you're exhausting yourself and it's
mixed in with like the thing you have to
do later your childhood trauma that one
song that you heard in 1991 all of that
is going into your reading which is why
you can't focus and when people read
words like if we read the Honeydew I
would see it right to left you see it as
a logo so if that was misspelled I
couldn't even tell you I see it just
looks like the circle logo yeah I
couldn't spell check which made it
really hard when I jumped on Twitter and
was trying to roast people and it was
all misspellings you lose immediately
when did you at 16 I got Hooked on
Phonics from eBay you really did I got
the book Hooked on Phonics was a
children's yeah we all used to joke
about Hooked on Phonics all the time and
when I was 18 I started going to open
mics I would put the Hooked on Phonics
in between my notepad and pretend that I
was like writing jokes but I was really
just like learning like What syllables
were and sounding Out words because it
was so embarrassed I knew it was a
children's book there's like a turtle
with glasses in the cover so if any
comic found that it went the [__] you
can't read what are you doing yeah
so you couldn't really fully read until
how old 18 then start till now how old
are you 32 now so here's the thing is
like I'll go to table reads and most of
it is dyslexia because I've done as much
as I can in my end to read but for the
sitcoms I've been on you have to do the
table reads but you get this script for
the first time writers just finished it
and it's these blocks where you have to
read and you got to hit the joke you
have to hit the timing it's spaced a
certain way and I have just built up a
confidence to like ask people can I get
the script before I know it's not a
thing but I will eat [__] at a table
read because I can't read and then you
have all these eyes on you so you start
to panic and you know that you're gonna
mess it up and some writer like they're
really proud of that one joke that's the
maybe they're the new writer and that's
the one joke that they got into the
episode and then you just blew it
because you couldn't time it out now
they cut the joke so now as much as I
can to ask for it
or if I've just got enough confidence
and know how to be like oh if I mess
something up I can explain that it's a
disorder but before then before I was
tested it was just so much shame around
not being able to read as an adult it's
something that's so practical it doesn't
matter how many fights Floyd might
rather wins you could always decimate
him with you can't read right right you
can't read that's that's that doesn't
matter he's the greatest fighter of all
time you can't read
so uh it's still it still does affect my
adult life more than I would like to
acknowledge or admit to myself how what
ways is it
um just the security of of knowing how
to read feeling like you're smart
feeling like you're just an equal to
someone it's something in Psychology
it's called learned helplessness if you
learn some certain behavior that you're
not good at singing or you're not good
at reading or you're awkward at a young
age it's called learned helplessness and
then you carry that behavior around for
the rest of your life
so even if I did read something
correctly I would still be second
guessing it even if you were singing in
a group you were the best you would feel
like oh I'm no good I'm I'm bad at this
and then that makes you not even try at
that thing so you wouldn't even get
hooked on fines you wouldn't even try to
do these things you're like I'm no good
at that you sell yourself short before
you've even started but your mom and dad
could read yes they could because they
went to Publix they're just not teaching
you my dad's incredibly intelligent but
not teaching you how to read no so how
do you pick up writing then especially
as a comedian at what what came first
for you uh you're making your sign
you're spelling your little uh God hates
gays Christians
so she would misspell signs all the time
if we were going without my dad because
he might be yeah she said one time I
said you're headed for heal I [__]
you're not like it's a shoe sale that's
great
oh God if she was ever out alone she'd
have to do a double check because yeah
so good
um but she but he's very intelligent my
mom is the most charismatic person
you've ever met so outgoing you'd think
that oh my God that lady's so cool she's
your best friend
so I picked up a lot of those skills
she would get caught shoplifting all the
time and then talk her way out of it
we've been at Walmart and she was like
horrible at stealing but great at
talking yourself out of that
and then my dad is just naturally very
intelligent so everything I have that
I'm able to adapt is from him it's just
his natural brain ability that he's
passed down
um but still there's these debits and
knowledge that I don't have
I think we were talking this earlier
it's never been easier though to be
uneducated in the modern era of
Technology now if I'm like telling you
oh hey I'm gonna come today I can do
that from speak to text
not to worry about spelling it out uh
this stuff's misspelled these days we
just assume it's voice to text yeah it
didn't pick it up you don't know how to
spell there or there yeah yeah so that
part is getting easier the part that is
hard now like let's say the low part is
in personal relationships now if I'm
with a girl
um and I've had multiple girlfriends and
it kind of falls apart for the same
reason where there's all these social
skills that I don't have and coping
mechanisms that you would learn if
you're around kids your age if you went
to a school and you had a girl that you
liked didn't like you back
um a girl liked you that you didn't like
back a bully that's the only thing
that's ever talked about in isolation
and homeschool is like kids need friends
they need friends right you also need
bullies man I'm glad you say that I've
been people taking shots at me for
saying that but I know for damn certain
that the kid in our neighborhood who
[__] with us
made me a better person I eventually
stood up to him because here's the thing
there's always bullies all in life yes
you protect your kid from the bullies
everywhere how many comedians do we know
that are that are bullying so many so
many pieces of [__] audience members
drunk bullies it's a constant part of
life people like to say oh my God my job
is just like high school everything is
like high school those same social
structures those same 100 even if the
bully doesn't bother you to see that
bully behave in a way and someone else
you know to know how you may react it's
it's I completely agree whether you
empathize with them be like oh I hope it
doesn't [__] with me or you feel guilty
for not doing anything or you're like I
kind of agree with that bullet yes yes
because he's very complex things the
most valuable thing that you learned in
your shitty public school with your
teachers that didn't give a [__] was
those social structures around you of
how to cope with people your age around
you that are doing the same thing this
is the most valuable skill you can show
me any testing scores for homeschooled
kids and then they get to go to school
they can go graduate college at 16. it's
like yeah you save a lot of time when
you're not building Precious Memories
you could finish school pretty fast when
I first heard about athletic greens and
decided give them a try I really wanted
to boost in energy and it's now become
part of my morning routine which means
I'm starting every day feel like I'm
doing something great for my body more
than just greens it's all your key
Health Products like multivitamins
minerals pre and probiotics and more
working together as one with just one
scoop I get the nutrients and gut health
support that helps my whole body Thrive
and covers my nutritional basis it's
made with 75 high quality vitamins
minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients that deliver benefits like
mood immune system and sleep support
sustained energy and so much more so if
you want to take ownership of your
health today is a good time to start
athletic greens is giving you a free
one-year supply of vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase go to athleticgreens.com
honeydew that's athletic greens.com
honeydew and check it out this podcast
is sponsored by better help do you ever
find that just as you're trying to fall
asleep your brain suddenly won't stop
talking your thoughts start racing right
before bed or other inopportune moments
I know for me I am my absolute most
creative just as I'm falling asleep just
as I'm slipping into that deep sleep my
mind wants to come up with all the ideas
and it turns out one great way to make
those racing thoughts go away is to talk
them through therapy gives you a place
to do that so you can get out of your
negative thought cycles and find some
mental peace all right you know we are
big on Mental Health here you know we're
big on therapy here believe it's
absolutely a muscle you need to work out
as well so if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online it's designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule you just fill out a brief
questionnaire you get matched with a
licensed therapist and you can switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge get a break from your thoughts
with better help visit betterhelp.com
honeydew today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash honeydew now let's get
back to the do so that stuff that I feel
I can get away with with friends Comics
before you go up set with like these
things that aren't weird or me being a
little [__] or lashing out but when I'm
intimate with with a girl with really
with someone and your your guard's down
and blood sugar's low you're tired or
you just woke up you're in a bad mood
um those coping skills to express what
I'm going through and what I'm feeling
and not feel like I'm bad for having
those feelings these human feelings and
being comfortable around someone is a
part that I'm feeling today
today as in like yesterday at 4 P.M yeah
yeah feeling that so the the most
harmful thing about the cult is the
present day is leaving
so what age do you finally are you out
by the way yeah I am out and what is
that that's the embarrassing part is
when you feel like you're not out
so as a kid it was this thing it's like
oh it's so embarrassing to go up to
adults and scream at them in a Walmart
but if it's just that thing that your
parents do I had no other reality there
was nothing to compare it to to be like
oh I wish I was doing this thing instead
of this we were so isolated we didn't
talk to anyone else that was not one of
the three families in the call so when I
got out at 16 I was so psyched so they
ran out of money the whole thing falls
apart okay wait so you didn't leave
while it was actively happening it fell
apart so you were able to get out yeah
do you think your family would have
supported you leaving if it was still
going absolutely not no no you'd have
been exiled which is like why a lot of
people stay in Jehovah's Witnesses
because they really Exile you and even
worse they let you come to all the
meetings but then you have to sit in a
separate section and they shun you ah
really really my older sisters Jehovah's
Witness now everyone kind of found their
own religion to latch onto and I used to
have nothing but it's embarrassing to
admit I want something
like just that something what to believe
yeah or okay yeah some sort of structure
to make this all make sense because
that's how I grew up and it was a very
sure thing is love not enough no because
that can go away you could lose that you
can mess that up
or you don't trust it when it is real
love I mean I gotta say your mom and dad
must have loved each other
to do this together like that as [__]
up as it may be to call yeah it seems
like at least they
truly loved one another and bought in
online
it wasn't or it wasn't with her for her
body
I like how it makes its own water
somebody flaps
oh man
um but yeah I think there has to be some
love there I think that I never saw them
like a hug or kiss or anything they were
not very affectionate
um and of course it was just like very
busy business okay here's how business
they were this is a as I just found this
out so I I I thought growing up that
people on the news like the news anchors
I thought that every male female news
anchor was married
that's the chemistry that my parents had
looks like it's gonna be a hot one out
there yeah well bring an umbrella sure
is Jim yeah that's the chemistry that
they had okay that I presume that all
news anchors were married
so yeah there has to be some love there
sure
um so it's 16 it falls apart they go
through a divorce when I'm uh 11. okay
10 or 11 but stay in Nicole we are in
Florida now we've um my dad would insist
on writing out hurricanes even though we
lived in that bus
Florida's constantly hit with hurricanes
most people leave the people that don't
leave that you see getting rescued on
the news are people that cannot afford a
ride out of there they don't have a car
or they have nowhere to go there's no
relatives they have out of state
we were in a bus
so literally you had a ride out of there
the the place that we have to go to is
also our rides it's all Wheels we have
everything right there but he would
insist like God's Gonna protect us we're
going to ride it out uh most of them
they got away with that one time God
didn't protect us
Hurricane Earl and everyone at clear out
of this this the Sea Grove Campground it
was so close to the beach uh the bus
gets blown back into a tree tree falls
in the back and it it it damages the
entire roof in the back uh everyone's
safe but then to then we move into a
double wide trailer park the bus in the
front and then my dad stays in the bus
for quote repairs
so he never moves back in he stays in
the bus to focus on repairs and then he
starts according to my mom starts seeing
um another man from his construction
site that he met
they go out uh they go to like Mardi
Gras together he comes back with pierced
ears he's really finding himself and
then my mom gets breast implants she
dyes her hair blonde and then dies all
of us blonde so no one knows that she's
not a natural blonde no yup come on dude
this is me it went all the way that far
to make sure
that you can show that other podcast
that's me uh that's not you that's me at
11. hot little girl
I was getting a hit on I would go to the
skate park and it would do a trick be
like yeah girl scouter
score one for the lady she's like so
your mom can pull off um
and then put a grocery bag on our heads
so it heats up so it takes even even
longer so it's just like hot bleach on
her head
um and then she goes out clubbing all
night she goes to Club La Villa in
Panama City Florida it's a big spring
break yeah yeah Panama City she gets a
job as a dancer there she starts living
her wild 20s that she never got to live
when she was repressed in this call my
dad goes off with Dennis and I think now
his new wife is where he met and then
we're just kind of left to our own so
what he has a wife now now he has a wife
why
I think he might be bi or or my mom
might be uh because we had no contact
with him she really isolated us from him
oh well so once they divorced you got
isolated from your own like he would
come over and try to do his visitation
and then we wasn't he right out front in
the bus he was and then he moved back
then he then he moved into a campground
okay I didn't clear that up
um and then the divorce paperwork in
Florida my mom gets full custody of all
five children provided and I guess my
dad agreed to this provided he gets
custody of the bus
he just wants the bus he doesn't love
you your father doesn't love you
no so he gets custody of the boss which
again you know
and do whatever he wants with it
um but then we break into the bus when
he's out partying with Dennis to steal
the um cult tapes that the cult leader
would record so my mom would would
uh take me in the middle of the night
wake me up and uh have me slide through
the window of this bus window that never
closed it was broken and I would slip in
and I would steal all the uh the tapes
from him
and then you know you see a remnants of
uh uh someone having sex maybe there's
condoms out maybe there's some handcuffs
out in the bus and I didn't know what it
meant I was like ooh dad's playing cops
and robbers yeah
um so then so then my mom just moves us
to California in the middle of the night
shows up like we didn't even know this
was happening shows up with a large
U-Haul truck and just shovel stuff in
the back nothing's even in boxes it's
loose it looks like a pile of junk
get we get on the road and we put the
our we had like four bunny rabbits in
the in the and we're Towing the 16
passenger van we called my dad from
Texas and then she lets him know that
hey we left
um we're gonna stay with my uncle in
California and we're not there anymore
and he was like missing for two days
because he was out partying or whatever
so that was really the last we saw them
for maybe 15 years holy [__] yeah and
because he didn't have his visitation
because he couldn't see us he stopped
paying child support so things get
really brutal because we moved to
California which is so expensive
and my mom's doing like odd jobs single
mom with five kids five kids that's like
50 kids no child support eventually we
get government assistance
um so then the cult stuff is really
falling apart there's no money there's
no bus to go on yeah
it is falling apart I think yeah I'm not
accepting it it's all right it's over
still standing standing right
I realized I was like no it's still
coming we're still doing it we're still
taking it we just gotta get back on our
feet it's over wait did it ever get a
name did it ever again no it never even
named it very briefly had the name the
way but then there's a way more
successful cult that called the way that
started in the early 90s
there's way more way they had like six
families they crushed us
so then
um so then the cult leader comes back
into the picture your uncle yeah this is
Dad's brother by the way no this is
Mom's Uncle mom's Uncle
because we're really not doing well my
oldest sister runs away she's now living
on the streets
um she's addicted to meth uh she's maybe
doing some other things to that to pay
for that math that's that's pretty
tragic and awful to see is that here in
La is that where you came to downtown
L.A well I think my mom was was trying
to control her
so she ran away the first time my mom
convinced her to come back and then she
said oh yeah we'll [__] leave then if
you're gonna leave and then didn't give
her any money didn't give her her ID
no money just a backpack of food so she
had to start her life on her own no
education no money no ID so it's like
how is she gonna end up she was 18.
Jesus yeah so then immediately falls
into the wrong crowd never been around
people so so easily taken advantage of
yeah so naive so wide like oh what's
that I'll get in that van I grew up in a
van so
um so then the cult leader comes back in
and it's like completely gaslights us
like why are you guys not prepping for
the future and so because you said this
was all going to be over in the year
2000 like this is the stuffer so he's
like well you guys need to get jobs you
need to sustain your lives and you can't
keep living like this you're just always
on the verge of homelessness I mean
we're living in a garage with no running
water
no running water uh there's no toilet
and how are you open this time now uh
now I'm
probably 15. damn
so then at 16 I get a job at a grocery
store all the siblings get their job
whether it's a babysitting for my
younger sister or my brother gets a job
at Lowe's and then the brother works at
a grocery store I go to a grocery store
it's like a shittier grocery store but
they had a trash compactor which was so
important to me because I didn't want my
mom I didn't want people at the store
knowing that my mom goes through
people's trash for food every grocery
store they knew her because like oh
that's the lady with the five kids
that's always in the dumpster
and I'm just like I want to do my own
thing it's so humiliating I can't have
you there so then I got a job at this
store and I really fought for it because
they had a trash compactor that's her
greatest enemy that and hair dye photos
but
I get a job there and that's the first
time that I'm around people my age
and so you get the first bully there you
get the first trying to interface with
people it's the first girl I like there
and there's someone there that she's
very kind to me she's very smart I think
now she's a double PhD
um as she's an engineer but it was the
first person that I was in love with was
kind to me I told her my beliefs and
then just those things that I believed
about the world how God was going to end
it how she was gonna burn in hell and
everyone else just hearing that back
from someone that was kind and caring
and was willing to hear me out and of
course you're horny and you want to be
with that person was enough to just
light switch I'm really programmed like
that
of course there was always doubts it
never went well so he's doubting but
there was no huge uh deprogramming
moment of The Wizard of Oz behind the
curtain it was just like talking to
someone that was kind to me and wasn't
forcing me out of this it was just
someone that listened to me and like oh
and they would ask me questions well why
would God make why would God only save
eight people and why are you street
preaching to other people if God's only
Gonna Save eight people like in the days
of Noah why would you be street
preaching and spreading the words of the
competition
and it was all these contradictions and
just the way I felt about her felt like
love that felt real and everything
before that with the religion felt like
oh that's that's [__] because that
hurts that feels bad this feels like
life
um I had no skills to make her my
girlfriend or even tell her that I liked
her
um but did try anyways even though she
was with someone else
I think I told her uh we eventually got
together it was a short-lived thing it
wasn't like your soulmate it was just
someone that was so kind to me and
changed your life and changed my life
yeah do you feel for the better oh yeah
yeah absolutely absolutely I mean the
only regret saying I wish that happened
earlier
do you ever have you ever reached out to
her to say thank you no I don't know I
almost feel bad it was like it's creepy
how much this person means to me and how
I could maybe even just be a blip on her
radar and also she doesn't owe me
anything sure something else she's
already giving me so much it's like yeah
if she ever came to me in need of course
of course you could have anything but
you know I wouldn't want to interfere
with her life and just like I just want
to re-un pack my pain with you this
trauma dump on you I don't see any
benefit for her if there was anything I
could do of course but that's my first
experience getting out and as soon as I
turned 18
uh got out of the house as soon as I
could move to Los Angeles
um still paying rent on my mom's house
which was where at the time
um in the in the desert of California
like two hours north of L.A and she
changed my name so I was born Sturm
s-t-u-r-m which is the German word for
Store Moses s-t-u-r-m okay and then so
first my Dad starts making and back in
Florida when they're still going through
their messy divorce my dad starts making
I guess protest art against her where he
would draw her in her like Club get up
when she got to Club La Vela which is
like jean shorts black halter top high
like black socks and like teased up
blonde hair damn mom yep big old tippies
out just like a travel neck pillow of
titties and then he drew her with like a
split snake ton in Hell standing on a
pile of burning potties grabbing men's
dicks and tongues in her hands like
their whips almost and then he had an
art show and then everyone in the town
saw this oh no he also Drew this one he
got he drew Jesus on the cross but with
the dung out
is hanging down
he was a shower yeah he was a shower
I guess it makes sense now okay God yeah
um get up on that cross why is your dad
mad that she's out doing her thing if
he's not
I think because she's like keeping the
kids from him ice and and telling a very
one-sided story of like you're she would
say like your dad's a pedophile he likes
to hook up with men oh like you don't
know what that is those are two
different things
so I think he was just mad at that and
the double standard of her calling him
out for trying to live his 20s out and
and then her doing the same thing and on
top of that keeping the kids from moving
the kids away not telling him
um so I think yeah so he that was his
way of like lashing out
um didn't try to reach out to us though
or didn't send child support anyways
which is its own thing so you reconnect
with him 15 years later 15 years later
which is what almost just a few years
ago for you yeah so then I yeah so I
just talked to him by Point Blank but
how could we never sure yeah how what
what made you connect Facebook he hit
you up or you his new wife which was
like hard to swallow because like do you
even want to do this because he's got a
wife that's just like my mom someone
that wears the pants in the family
someone that's very bold and outgoing so
it was always hard to like uh trust like
does he really want this or is it you
just trying to get your wife off your
back
um but yeah I was very kind and crazy
and my wife's not always yeah
she makes her own water
um yeah so then we reconnect and yeah
it's just like very awkward now
and that was the reconnection it's just
very awkward you know that's a long time
going from a kid to a man now and now
you're talking to the man that put you
in that position she's always wanted
more from like reach out like show me
that you care because where was he the
whole time you're in California stayed
in Florida
um I don't know I don't want some
dramatic thing but you would expect that
they'd be a little more enthused about
it but it always felt like his wife was
making him do it
and there was no acknowledgment when it
was like well did you ever why didn't
you try to come reach out like go I if
my kids if my dog was in in New York I
would go to New York and try to find my
dog yes myself right and I wouldn't give
up he's like well I did go there for
like a uh like a weekend and I was on
the Sunset Boulevard I was like yeah
that's where we were we were living it
out by the sunset but we're doing coke
with Johnny Depp and the Phoenix
Brothers
so
um yeah so it's just like awkward but
there's no hard feelings the complicated
part now again everything about the cult
is just complicated now were you the
only sibling uh he reached out to like
are you the only one that's right no he
tried everyone I don't know what the
order is of who got in touch because
every kid is spread out everyone's in
their own state
uh are you close with your siblings so
close all good yeah we I just saw my my
um sister yesterday she still lives up
in the desert
um and and has a new baby but we just
talk and it's you cannot talk for a
couple months and it just feels like you
yeah picked up because we grew up
literally on top of each other literally
yes mattress on top my older brother
slept above me but there's a mildew
Stang because he would pee the bed every
night no and it would drip through all
right we put him up top why why are we
putting the white one I remember just
like as a kid poking the the mildewy
I wonder if I get him to fall through
like a cartoon man
um I want to ask you a question you
don't have the answers if you don't want
to but it's and we can cut it out if
you'd like as well my producer Kirsten
told me a story about Jared Leto and
your mom yes and we want to know I I
don't know anything other than that is
it okay to talk about this yes oh my God
what is this all about
um so uh so we moved to California for
doing odd job she gets a job as a pa
um through my uncle she's immediately
fired because she keeps leaving to go
work out or or just [__] around or like
overstepping the boundaries with with
like Mariah Carey whatever but through
that she gets the idea in her head that
like a great way for the kids to make
money
is uh I should already change my name to
storm which is the art name that my dad
was going under he was going under the
English translation storm makes me
technically emancipated so when she
later gets a is that right yeah
so uh so I'm separate from her and her
last name
co-signed with her on a house when the
mortgage crisis was going on yes guess
who got a house yeah guess who that that
was the biggest red flag is that we were
able to get a house on our no money but
my job is um a stunt double on sets as a
child stunt doctor are you for real yes
but we she had forged all the paperwork
I did not go through any of the safety
training I don't know anything about
wire work or anything and I get a job on
on Lemony Snicket A Series of
Unfortunate Events the Jim Carrey remake
and I'm doing so much dangerous [__]
wire work where there's a part where the
house breaks apart and have to jump from
one side of the house to the other no
idea what I'm doing one time I just I
I'm so exhausted from that that I throw
up all over the set
um and like it pass out because I just
wasn't used to any of this stuff through
that that leads to like half quasi
audition didn't work so we we auditioned
for
from the Libby's naked thing
um Jared those putting on his first
album
Capricorn whatever and um they're gonna
audition kids they're gonna be like the
kid versions of this band Meaning we're
going to be on the album cover which I
think you can look up on on the album
jacket if you look up the Capricorn One
um and everyone's gonna be a young
version of anyone in that band so we go
to the audition and then Jared's like
well not just the album cover we want
these kids in the music video I'm going
to bring you guys out a concert and come
out with us
through that
um I think this is when he's with
Cameron Diaz or just broke up with
Cameron Diaz because we're filming the
album cover at her house uh my mom is is
super into fitness she's always lifting
weights she brings dumbbells on an
airplane
so like she'll have a carry-on bag and
the guy was like let me help you with
that Miss and then throw his back out
drinking
guys for you she's got 50 pounds
what the [__] was in that
um so then Jared Leto and her start
flirting because she's like a hot mom I
don't say that people say that
um and she's always working out she's
working out on set the whole time so
he's trying to get in shape or that's
what his story was and he said you
should be my personal trainer
um so then I don't know what happened
but they there's a few times that she
went to visit him we weren't there
and then we get on a music video shoot
we're doing I don't know what this song
was but if the music video it's like if
you want to see it I'm in the video but
it's like we're in a dirt pit everyone's
in a dirt pit and it's like a big party
of people taking their tops off
um and sending out the hoods and then so
we're out in the desert Stevenson Ranch
I think in California
and Jared's there and he he he's like
let me let me take you on a walk
and I don't know if he was like trying
to suck up to my mom and get closer
there or he's like gonna give me like
I'm your new dad now which I would have
totally taken
um but one the whole day he's like
saying everyone's got to stay hydrated
you guys should be peeing every five
seconds and then he'll come out five
minutes later say the same thing again
because we're in the desert he's like
let's go to the bathroom everybody
should be peeing if you're hydrated
right so then he's like come on come
take a walk with me
and so then him and I are walking it's
dirt field there's like fake Western
sets all over there's no crew around the
trailer and then he just starts to sing
to me
just acapella his own song No from the
music video yeah you're just walking and
he's just walking and then he gets to a
point where it's like a little more
effort that he stops and then I stopped
too
and you just it's so quiet like you
could hear like the tires and the
distance going over gravel of like
production trucks
and I don't know what to say I mean this
is like one of the first adults I've
ever interacted with in my life that I
didn't say you're going to hell
um so yeah if that's the story she was
talking about but then yeah he just
sings to me acapella and I'm like
that was that was good
do you need approval from a child ah
then you just go back and that's it yeah
let me just go back and I I try to avoid
him at any moment if I see him walking
ahead like we're gonna be alone
I just I I don't have those knowledge to
I just know I don't want to be around
that so that might avoid him ever since
um all right so let's wrap up with this
here now you're free of at least for now
an organized religion or a belief but
you're looking for something yeah so
what where
I'm not actively looking okay there's no
self-help there's no power of now but
what is it that you miss about even
though we've we've talked about what
we've talked about and busted and three
families what is it you miss about the
structure and the sureness is why most
people will believe in Immaculate
Conception in a talking snake the things
in life the older you get the more you
make mistakes the more this gets scary
or confronted with your own mortality
painful things happen last year I lost a
really close friend
um so there's all these things you have
to deal with and if there was something
that made sense even if it was a Genie
in a Bottle and you know Abraham lived
for 900 years yeah sure he did that
would be so comforting to have some
reason for this let this happen for a
reason and that this is all for the
better and to know that to know that
this isn't it to know that this is over
so I'm hyper aware that that's why
that's a good point of life is like
we're supposed to go through these
things and not know but at times I just
feel very Wicked that some stuff is so
painful that I wish I had it even if it
meant being in a bus and
going through all that pain
listen thank you very much for coming on
here and opening up about this it's such
a such a different upbringing
um so thank you now I asked all people I
told you before your first time here I'm
curious now after everything we've
talked about advice you would give to
your 16 year old self
oh man one you're right about how you
feel doubting this
um that's great also you're okay and
enough
um I don't know we're always told that
we were that you're you're weird you're
special you're chosen by God
um so then that even if that's a
positive you're another chosen you
always feel like this other
and I think I just wanted to blend in
just wanted to be like someone to say
like you're okay exactly as you are with
your thoughts that you have the way you
interact with people that's enough you
don't have to dance around and do skits
you don't even have to do stand up I
just couldn't read or write at 18 when
everyone's asking you what you're gonna
do
so I I wanted to be a lawyer but I
couldn't I would have to get a GED you
have to go to school I'd have to battle
all those feelings of stupidity so I
don't even know if I would be a
performer if all that stuff didn't
happen it was just the one thing I was
kind of good at
and then I had all my stunt training uh
throwing up and taste of that so it was
the one career I thought I could dig
myself out of generational poverty but
yeah I would just be like yeah you're
gonna be okay and you could take time to
do what you want
it's great
um please plug and promote anything
you'd like again uh trash white on HBO
Max HBO
um that's my our special and then the
part two of that I'm touring around and
trying to work on that that's called
perfect cult about the stuff you heard
today about how we didn't grow up in a
cult and then trying to create that
perfect version of that call with the
audience new cult every night Elation
theater on July 30th at 9 00 pm and then
go into the Edinburgh Fringe Festival in
Scotland the Pleasants Theater 10 P.M
every single night running perfect call
in Scotland and then coming back to Los
Angeles uh September 30th I think that's
at nine uh to do perfect cult again in
Los Angeles everything's at
mosestorm.com and then mainly on on
Instagram everything's mozastar from
Tick Tock Twitter threads almost a storm
awesome go support Moses uh as always
Ryan sickler on all social media Ryan
sickler.com go get your tickets for the
tour at Ryan Circle dot com we'll talk
to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
please